[music playing]
[clock ticking]
NARRATOR: Not everything goes
the way you want it to go.
You don't get to choose
how life unfolds.
You just get to live it.
Looks like I've got
good moving water,
but it looks like it's
out there quite a ways.
Right now here in Kavik, this
is the changing of the seasons.
Winter is letting go and
the springtime is coming in.
My list of chores is long.
But the most important
one that opens up first
is get running water to camp.
How do I get water?
I have hose.
I have to run it all the
way down to the river,
put it in the river,
pump it all the way up,
filter it, treat it, and
then send it around camp
where I want it.
That's stagnant right they're.
Not interested in that.
Why is it important to
have rapidly moving water?
In a stagnant pond, what
do you get if you're down
south maybe in the lower world?
Tadpoles, slime-- you're
going to get sick.
So stagnant water--
big fat no, no.
Moving water keeps it
clean, keeps it oxygenated.
That's what you want.
I've got nice water action
coming down this way.
It's moving.
I may be able to just
get it right here.
The melting ice doesn't
have a lot of issues.
So what I think I want to
do is get the water line,
set it out so it
can finish thawing,
and then go from there.
You can see my pipe is encased
in a little bit of ice.
So my favorite piece of
equipment is a sledge.
When you run into a problem, you
can just kind of sledge it out.
Alaska is known
for its resources--
oil, gold-- but the one as
residents we desire the most
is that liquid water.
That's what we call the gold.
I've had a good nine, 10 months
with no running water in camp.
A nice hot shower
is not a bad thing.
And especially this last year
with COVID, the importance
of keeping everything
hygienically clean
can't be overstressed.
Who said Mike
doesn't make right?
Wasn't somebody
with a sledgehammer.
I guarantee you that.
Not bad for a fat old
chick on the tundra.
That's the pipe.
And it can lay out here.
There's going to be
frozen bits inside.
Even in a cloudy state, that
sun will work on that, melt it,
so when I need to use it, it's
free of that and it can flow.
I'll let this be, let
nature start working on it,
go inside, and warm up.
[music playing]